far below the ocean's surface life has
adapted to a world of Darkness
strange creatures haunt the crushing
depths some of them completely blind
others with eyes that point upwards to
help them avoid Predators attacking from
higher levels others still have eyes so
enormous you begin to wonder if it's so
dark at these depths what are these eyes
designed to see no sunlight penetrates
the deep water of the ocean but this
ecosystem is by no means devoid of light
it instead shines with one of the most
widespread adaptations in the ocean
bioluminescence
many creatures have evolved the ability
to glow in the dark either by harnessing
bioluminescent bacteria or initiating a
chemical reaction within their own
bodies these unique adaptations have
intrigued scientists for decades but
more recently researchers have realized
bioluminescence isn't limited to the
darkest parts of the ocean
in fact the proportion of animals that
glow is similar at all levels of the
ocean from the surface down to the sea
floor
bioluminescence is less a special
ability than a widespread adaptation in
the sea more than 75 percent of
organisms in the ocean can produce their
own light from the smallest bacteria all
the way up to large sharks fishes and
Rays have evolved to this feature at
least 29 different times making it an
impressive example of convergent
evolution
and if you consider that 71 of the
earth's surface is water that means
bioluminescence is actually one of the
most widespread traits to have ever
evolved but that also raises the
question why is bioluminescence so
common in the ocean and so rare on land
the only terrestrial organisms with the
ability to produce their own light are a
few species of fungi arthropods like
fireflies and a handful of larvae like
glowworms and while the ocean is
certainly a dark place our terrestrial
world is bathed in darkness half the
time too if bioluminescence isn't in
fact limited to the pitch black depths
of the ocean why does it seem to be
constrained to barely exist on land
what is it about the world of water that
makes it so much more suited to
bioluminescence
when 18th and 19th century Travelers
wrote about glowing water on the ocean
their accounts were dismissed as fantasy
Jules Verne described a Milky light
coming from the ocean in his popular
novel 20 000 Leagues Under the Sea but
it wasn't until the 21st century that we
were able to understand that the
phenomenon of glowing really can
illuminate huge patches of the ocean
today we know that bioluminescence has
emerged independently more than 94 times
within hundreds of species organisms
that use bioluminescence have two
options for producing their own light
they can use intrinsic bioluminescence
in which they mix chemicals in their own
bodies to produce photons of various
colors and intensities
or they can use symbiotic
bioluminescence which requires
cultivating colonies of glowing bacteria
in specialized organs the chemical
process involves a molecule called
luciferin that generates light when
mixed with oxygen and a luciferase
enzyme
luciferin and luciferase are generic
catch-all terms in reality there are
many different molecules that can be
combined to catalyze this light emitting
reaction this process likely originated
with bacteria and some researchers
hypothesize its incredibly ancient the
first bioluminescence may have appeared
between 2 billion and 500 million years
ago
however the two different types of
bioluminescence that exist today have
very different evolutionary histories
researchers found that intrinsic
bioluminescence only evolved eight times
in fishes but that symbiotic
bioluminescence has happened at least 17
times always with the same family of
bacteria
on land the trait seems to have taken
longer to appear a fossilized ancestor
of fireflies from a hundred million
years ago was discovered to have a light
producing organ suggesting that this has
long been an adaptation among that group
and it probably originated as a form of
Defense to warn off Predators another
group of researchers have suggested that
other bioluminescent terrestrial insects
evolved from a single ancestor that
lived 65 million years ago around the
time that dinosaurs went extinct and
mammals took over but that doesn't
explain fungi since they belong to a
whole other branch on the Tree of Life
researchers analyzed the Genome of
living fungi to trace the roots of
glowing mushrooms back to 160 million
years ago they theorized that this
bioluminescent ability evolved from one
common ancestor that then was either
lost retained or regained across time
and many different species
it's possible that the effect makes
spores more attractive to Insects who
might spread them but bioluminescence
might also be a byproduct of other
chemical reactions which would explain
why it's disappeared multiple times
through the evolutionary history of
fungi if it was serving no secondary
purpose it wouldn't need to be retained
but the fact that bioluminescence has
evolved separately on land and has been
retained in several species means that
it is a useful land-based adaptation so
why is it still so rare what about the
ocean makes bioluminescence so
ubiquitous
living in the ocean is not at all like
living on land
the most obvious difference between
marine and terrestrial environments is
the medium water versus Air
both present vastly different challenges
and opportunities to life forms who live
in them but a less obvious difference is
the fact that in most of the ocean
there's nowhere to hide rodents and
other small animals on land have trees
shrubs rocks and Burrows that help them
stay safe from predators
meanwhile for most aquatic life there's
nothing in the environment to keep them
safe Reef systems are the exception
rather than the rule they only occur in
about one percent of the ocean and only
some species live on the ocean's floor
nearly everywhere else in the ocean is
an open expanse that means many species
have had to find other ways of keeping
themselves safe from predators and as
unexpected as it might be light is one
of the best methods
jellyfish and siphonophores are some of
the best examples of creatures that use
light to evade capture nearly all of
them have some form of bioluminescence
comb jellies flash brightly to startle
Predators while siphonophores can
produce a constellation of small lights
mimicking Plankton to confuse predators
some jellies even release a glowing
slime that sticks to their Predator a
strategy also employed by tiny
Crustaceans called ostrocods or sea
fireflies when fish try to swallow them
they release one of the brightest lights
in the ocean momentarily blinding the
fish and smearing it with light by
Illuminating themselves or their
Predator these organisms might also be
calling over an even larger Predator the
ones who might eat the smaller organisms
would be predator
consider dinoflagellates those
single-celled Plankton that can produce
such wonderfully glowing waves there are
many species of dinoflagellates and
those that are capable of
bioluminescence are less likely to be
eaten this could be because their bright
flashes act like a burglar alarm
essentially announcing to the nearby
ocean dwellers hey this crustacean is
trying to eat me you want to come eat
him the last way swimmers use light as a
source of Defense sounds the most
counter-intuitive light as camouflage
the deeper you go in the ocean the less
light filters down through all that
water
between 200 meters and a thousand meters
lies the mesopelagic also known as The
Twilight Zone because a certain amount
of light does come from above a fish
swimming above a predator would have its
dark silhouette outlined against the
light to keep this from happening they
use counter illumination little spots of
light on their Underside break up their
silhouette confusing potential Predators
it's such a well-honed trick that
creatures like the Hawaiian bobtail
squid can change the amount of light it
emits depending on the time of day like
its own glowing circadian rhythm
the story on land is a little more
complicated since lighting up in the
darkness is more likely to draw
attention to you than to obscure your
outline but this glow can still be a
defensive strategy for some organisms by
advertising that they are poisonous
it's like a nighttime version of the
poison dart Frog's vibrant skin color
this strategy is used by some worms as
well as millipedes
but of course it's not only prey who are
using light to keep themselves alive
Predators have many of their own tricks
to lure in their meals members of the
anglerfish family might be the best
known deep sea dwellers to entrance
their prey with glowing lures but the
strategy also seems to be used by giant
squid who have been observed flashing
Bright Lights while hunting either as a
way of stunning their prey or getting
them to come closer and this hunting
technique is something shared among many
of the bioluminescent insects that glow
on land
consider the glow worms that have
Enchanted people for centuries in
Australia and New Zealand these cave
dwellers fill the ceilings of their
abodes with Starry blue constellations
but that light is actually a creepy
hunting strategy the worms spin dripping
Nets of glowing spit into which other
insects fly the larvae of Click beetles
operate very similarly hiding in holes
and emitting a soft yellow green glow
whenever insects approach to investigate
the Beetles pincers snap shut around its
meal just like in the sea organisms on
land have been able to turn
bioluminescence to their advantage when
it comes to hunting but perhaps the most
mysterious use of bioluminescence is
light for mating and communication
scientists recently discovered that the
Humboldt squid a voracious Hunter uses a
number of different light patterns
depending on the context it's in these
changes might reflect messages that
they're communicating to other squid
whether it's dominance displays or
claiming certain prey and then there's
also the case of lantern fishes which
include more than 250 species swimming
around the mesopelagic in addition to
having lights on their stomachs for
camouflage purposes they also have
glowing spots on the sides of their
heads researchers have hypothesized that
different species have subtly different
glowing signals they use to find mates
if it's a strategy that sounds familiar
it might be because so many of us have
watched lightning bugs dance through the
darkness on summer nights these flying
beetles also use bioluminescence for
mating purposes with different species
flashing at different intervals to
attract mates but still light up
displays like Firefly dances are the
exception not the rule for life on land
despite its clear utility for some
creatures researchers think that it
might be harder for terrestrial life to
develop bioluminescence because the
chemicals involved can be quite toxic
and might be harder to cleanse away when
the creatures aren't always swimming
through water but this toxicity is
unlikely to be the full story as to why
bioluminescence isn't more common on
land since bioluminescence is also
basically non-existent in fresh water
where toxicity could be removed as well
as in the ocean the answer perhaps has
to do with something simpler time life
hasn't existed on land and in fresh
water as long as it has in the ocean and
evolution is a slow process
perhaps it's not that land-based
organisms don't have bioluminescence
it's that they don't have
bioluminescence yet
it's clear that we have a lot of work
yet to do to understand the past and
future of bioluminescence but if we ever
make it far enough into the universe to
discover life on other planets
scientists say we should be on the
lookout for bioluminescence because
where there's water and air there's a
pretty good chance we'll find lots of
glowing life
as millions of tiny vulnerable fish
navigate the dark ocean water so too do
millions of tiny vulnerable humans
navigate the abyss of the Internet it's
all too easy for us to fall victim to a
trap set by nefarious parties often in
the form of phishing attacks these are
carefully targeted digital messages that
are transmitted to fool people into
clicking on a link that can install
malware or expose sensitive data and
these attacks are evolving morphing
becoming more sophisticated as this
channel has grown I've gotten my fair
share of questionable emails some come
in the form of benign looking emails
that look like they're coming from other
members of my team others are so
extraordinarily over-the-top crazy
there's a human urge to let the
intrusive thoughts win and click the
links they send out of sheer curiosity
no one is totally immune to falling for
one of these traps and this is why I use
nordvpn threat protection which includes
a specific feature to warn you about
phishing links as well as features like
a blocker for malicious ads and dark web
monitoring to alert you if passwords
have been leaked and all these features
come with a robust VPN so you can
protect your data and unblock all the
content you want now go to norenvpn.com
real science to check it out and the
best part is that you can try it with no
risk Nord has a 30-day money-back
guarantee so you can try it for yourself
and see if you like it so go to
nordvpn.com real science to get the
two-year plan and four additional months
free and if you're looking for something
else to watch right now you can watch
our previous video about the insane
biology of sloths or you can watch real
engineering's latest video about the
surprising way that seat belts work